at this point after having covered for a
week I can't breathe very well
Brienne is feeling quite a bit better
and Dayton's kind of coming out of it
too Robin's not improving she's not
improving and finally our doctor just
says take her to the hospital people go
to the hospital to die
I was crying and praying and because I
was like scared that she might die
I didn't want to say goodbye to my kids
I didn't want to
say goodbye because I didn't want to be
the last time I saw them
[Music]
they wouldn't let me go in with her no
I'm blue as can be
so it's only one person at a time and I
kind of wish I'd admitted myself you
know because I do have it no doubt about
that
and maybe I need a chest x-ray
because you know my nights of sleep and
my breathing sort of suck
but I knew that they just separate us
so she see how she fares
if I was feeling worse I'd probably have
myself I'd check myself in you know but
it seems like a busy Hospital seems like
a waste for me to be going in there and
and playing sick
and there's people that might be dying
or Robin who's
um you know passing out
so
I'm going to check in with her and
see what's going on
open here at the hospital for
I think
six seven hours
waiting for
a room
they're backed up
and have a lot of beds
I'm sitting
in the truck there's nothing I can do I
can't I'm not going to be in the
hospital with her they wouldn't let me
wait there with her wouldn't let me go
with her didn't know what to do so after
quite a while I got on the phone with
her she sounds pretty bad I'm like she
says I'm sitting here
just wasting away
they've done an EKG
on me and they
um
and chest x-ray
I'm taking urine I'm
just waiting to see the doctor
I think that I was sitting there and
wondering if she was going to live